So,
um,
I want to recommend a book first to
everyone here.
It's called explaining postmodernism and
it's by a gentleman named Steven Hicks,
and you need to understand postmodernism
because that's what you're up against.
You're up against it far more than you
know or think,
and it's a much more well developed and
a pervasive pernicious,
nihilistic,
intellectually attractive doctrine than
has yet come to public realization.
It absolutely dominates the humanities
and increasingly the social sciences in
the universities.
And what's happening,
you see,
someone once said,
who unfortunately I can't remember.
It might've been Friedrich Nietzsche
said that everybody is the unconscious
exponent of a dead philosopher.
And uh,
fortunately the postmodern philosophers,
most of them are dead.
So that's a good thing.
But that doesn't mean that their words
aren't continually being spoken by
people who,
who are following in their wake,
let's say.
And it's not like any given person is
absolutely possessed,
say by the spirit of postmodernism,
because often they're not educated
enough to know all the details about
what it is that has them in their grip.
But if you get 20 of them together and
they're all five percent influenced by
the postmodernist ethos,
you basically have the spirit of the mob
that's a mouthpiece for that particular
philosophical doctrine.
And if you understand the doctrine,
then you understand why things are
progressing the way that they are
progressing.
And so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the doctrine because it's not
optional to understand this.
It's absolutely crucial to understand
this.
You can't underestimate the power of
ideas and also the power of words of
course,
because ideas are expressed in words,
but you see the postmodernists
completely reject the structure of
Western civilization.
And I mean completely.
So I can give you an example in one
term,
Jacques Derrida,
who's head trickster for the
postmodernist movement regarded Western
culture,
let's call it the patriarchy as fellow
goes centric.
Okay?
So follow comes from Fellas,
p h a l,
l o.
and so that's the insistence that what
you see in Western culture is the
consequence of a male dominated,
oppressive,
a self serving society.
And we might say,
well,
you know,
societies do tend to be self serving and
people in power do tend to act in their
best interests,
but a tendency is not an absolute and
that's one of the things that needs to
be considered continually.
There are no shortage of flaws in the
manner in which we've structured our
society and compared to any hypothetical
utopia,
it's an absolutely dismal rec,
but compared to the rest of the world
and the plight of other societies
throughout the history of mankind,
we're doing pretty damn well and we
should be happy to be living in the
society that we're living in.
So the first one
thing that you might want to note about
postmodernism is that it doesn't have a
shred of gratitude and there's something
pathologically wrong with a person who
does have.
It,
doesn't have any gratitude,
especially when they lived in what so
far is the best of all possible worlds.
And so if you're not great for a,
you're driven by resentment and
resentment is the boat the worst emotion
that you can possibly experience apart
from arrogancy,
resentment,
arrogance and deceit.
There's an evil triad for you,
and if you're bitter about everything
that's happening around you,
despite the fact that you're bathed in
wealth,
then there's something absolutely wrong
with you.
You know the black community in the
United States is the 18th wealthiest
community,
18th wealthiest nation on the planet.
Now,
that doesn't mean there isn't such a
thing as relative poverty in relative
poverty matters.
It's an important,
it's an important political economic
issue and it's very,
very difficult to deal with,
but absolute wealth matters too,
and and western societies have been
absolutely remarkable in their ability
to generate and distribute wealth.
As you can tell,
by just looking around,
taking a brief bit of consideration for
the absolute miracle that even a
building like this represents,
so you have to educate yourself about
postmodernism.
Okay,
so here's what the postmodernist belief,
they don't believe in the individual.
That's the logos park.
Western culture is fell logocentric logo
is logos.
That's partly the Christian word,
but it's also partly the root word of
logic,
okay?
They don't believe in logic.
They believe that logic is part of the
process by which the patriarchal
institutions of the West continue to
dominate and to justify their dominance.
They don't believe in dialogue.
The root word of dialogue is logos.
Again,
they don't believe that people of
goodwill can come to consensus through
the,
through the exchange of ideas.
They believe that that notion is part of
the philosophical substructure and
practices of the dominant culture,
so the reason they don't let people who
they don't agree with speak on campuses
because they don't agree with letting
people speak.
You see?
It's not part of the ethos.
Okay,
so what else do they believe and not
believe?
They believe that since you don't have
an individual identity,
your fundamental identity is group
fostered,
and that means that you're basically an
exemplar of your race,
hence white privilege,
or you're an exemplar of your gender or
your sex or your ethnicity or your an
exemplar of however you can be
classified so that you,
you are placed in the position of victim
against the oppressor because that's the
game and it's,
it's a,
it's a postmark sleight of hand,
right?
The old Marxist notion was that the
world was a battleground between the
Burj waze and the proletariat and that a
failed to have any philosophical or
ethical standing.
That argument after the working class
actually saw its standard of living
massively elevated as a consequence of,
of Western corporate democracy,
a Western free enterprise democracy,
and also be and and also as a
consequence of the revelations of
everything terrible that it happened in
every bloody country that ever dared to
make equity and,
and,
and the Marxist communist dogma part of
their fundamental structure,
right,
and nothing but murderousness and
oppression.
And so by the 19 seventies it was
evident that that game was up.
No postmark.
The postmodernist Marxist just barely
basically pulled a sleight of hand and
said,
okay,
if it's not the poor against the rich,
it's the oppressed against the
oppressor.
We'll just read,
divide the subpopulations in ways that
make our,
our bloody philosophy continue in its,
in its,
in its movement forward.
And that's where we're at now.
And so for the postmodernists,
the world is a hobbs Z and battleground
of identity groups.
They do not communicate with one another
because they can't.
All there is,
is a struggle for power and if you're in
the Predator group,
which means you're an oppressor,
then you better look out because you're
not exactly welcome.
Uh,
not exactly welcome and neither are your
ideas.
So that's what you're up against.
I would say it's time for conservatives
to stop apologizing for being
conservatives.
No,
you don't apologize to these people.
That's a big mistake.
Apology there.
They read apology as a,
as a,
as an admission of guilt.
You don't apologize and you don't back
down.
You young people that are out there who
are university students.
You need to take over the student
unions.
You need to take them back because
they're absolute snake pits and they
have been since the 19th.
Thank you.
And with regards with regards to the
universities,
I thought at one point that the best
thing to do would be to cut their
funding by 25 percent.
Let them fight amongst themselves for
the remnants because it would force the
universities to decide exactly what's
important and what isn't.
So I would say the humanities and much
of the social sciences have has turned
into a postmodern Neil Marxist
playground for radicals.
The scholarship is terrible.
Eighty percent of humanities papers
aren't cited once,
once,
and so what that means is that they
write papers for each other and they
sell them to libraries and that's how
the publishers make their money and no
one reads them,
but the publishers can print them
because the libraries have to buy them
and they're buying them with your tax
money and so all of you who are sitting
here,
our funding and postmodern radical neo
Marxist agenda that has its roots in the
university and your tax money is going
towards that and if you want proof of
that,
you just go online and look at the
websites,
especially of of disciplines like
women's studies,
which has pathological right to the
core,
but it's not just women's studies,
it's all the ethnic studies groups.
It's anthropology,
it's sociology,
it's social work,
and most of all it's education and
noisy.
For example,
in Ontario is perhaps a part from the
Ontario Human Rights Commission,
the most dangerous institution in
Canada.
It should,
it should be defunded.
It's as simple as that.
They don't do the research they purport
to do.
They're not interested in,
in,
at all,
in education.
They're interested in the indoctrination
of people as young as they can fund a as
young as they can get their hands on to
speak.
Now we need to figure out our society
needs to figure out how to stop shunting
public tax money to radical left wing
activists.
If we were doing that for radical right
wing activists,
there would be an absolute storm,
but it's happened incrementally since
the 19 sixties and it needs to stop.
So that's partly what the Conservatives,
not only conservatives,
but also liberals,
true liberals in the English sense are
up against.
I mean what's happened as also as a
consequence of this postmodern,
neo Marxist intellectual invasion,
is that the center keeps moving.
It's moved way to the right now.
So if you're a classic liberal,
you've become a conservative.
And so for all of you who are interested
in pursuing the conservative agenda,
there's a lot of classic liberals that
you could be talking to.
And then finally,
with regards to talking to young people,
you finally have something to sell to
them.
You know,
it's not easy to sell conservatism to
young people because they want to change
things and that's not what conservatives
want to do.
They want to maintain things.
Well,
now you've got something to sell to
young people.
You can sell them freedom of speech and
you can tell seldom responsibility.
The left is selling them,
right?
You can sell them responsibility.
And I can tell you because I received
many letters of the sort that,
that God was talking about,
young people are absolutely starving for
someone to provide them with a sense of
responsibility and say,
look,
here's something worth living for it,
man.
You know,
you can find meaning in life with
freedom.
But freedom.
Freedom is a chaotic sort of meaning,
right?
And freedom isn't the sort of thing that
makes people happy.
It's the sort of thing that makes people
troublesome,
troubled,
because freedom expands your.
You're a series of choices and that
makes you nervous and uncertain.
So,
but responsibility is another.
Not to say that that's a bad thing.
It's a good thing,
but it it,
it requires that you,
that you shoulder the responsibility of
the freedom,
but responsibility per se is what gives
your life meaning genuine meaning in the
face of suffering and you and young
people are really.
They're starving for that.
I've been teaching young people for 30
years and mostly what I've been teaching
them about his responsibility,
so like your arrows to a great
tradition.
It's not perfect obviously,
but comparatively the nerve,
there's nothing else like it that's ever
been produced and it's it.
It represents a tiny minority of,
of,
of human policies,
most of which are are,
are,
are run by murderous,
antisocial psychopathic thugs and that
seriously and so what kind of
alternative is that?
We've got this beacon of freedom and
wealth and the West that works,
although it doesn't work perfectly,
and one of the,
one of the responsibilities of young
people is to find out what's at the core
of that.
The great,
great core of that,
the paramount,
the paramount importance of the
individual and the divinity of speech.
Man,
that's something to sell.
It's what our whole culture is
predicated on.
Thank you.
All right,
well I should stop there,
so thank you very much for the
invitation.